vous allez les histoires je pense
on va commencer ma présentation par une
petite histoire
d'une petite fille
dans un village de nommer dit mûri
et dit maurice est un bateau de la
préfecture de bassar
gaza city au nord du togo
et c'est quoi l'histoire de cette petite
fille
née des paras paysage
ce à dire
l'activité principale des part à ces
essais sûrement sur l'agriculture
donc elle a accompagné ses parts à
auchan et accompagné aussi sa maman dans
ses activités
mais la
grl et dès ce moment à couper les rois
pour la cuisine
époux fait du tout
le juke pourquoi pas ce même à doit
subvenir aux besoins de la famille
du coup elle était devenue accro car la
bataille thésards
s'édifie un moment donné a remarqué
qu'ils avaient
un dérèglement de la nature du climat
par curiosité elle pose la question de
savoir pourquoi maintenant il ya la
rareté des pluies est pourquoi nous
avons nous remarquons maintenant la
chaleur à tout moment
et la réponse
c'est que c'est le la nature qui s'est
fâché des actions que nous menons tous
les jours malgré qu'elle ne parle pas
mais elle s'élève
comment c'est la question à se poser
en lydie l'eau voilà les preuves de ce
changement climatique
pourquoi nous vivons aujourd'hui le
réchauffement climatique
et dans les poses qu'on a énuméré
je me suis rendu compte que j'ai
participé aussi à dégrader
cette nature et voilà pourquoi s est
fâché ou jeudi elle est fatiguée
maintenant si j'ai contribué je peux
aussi amener ma pierre pour que cette
nature même si elle ne peut plus
retrouver sa forme d'avoir au moins
qu'on essaie d'atténuer les effets
néfastes que nous vivons aujourd'hui
et c'est là bas que
elle s'est mise à
chercher
les solutions adéquates
et elle a pensé
à aller vers ces moments les fin
mai
certains amis vous pourront se faisait
ici la question de savoir pourquoi
prendre pour cible la femme
pour une question qui concerne tout le
monde entier
si le prenons notre pays le togo
est selon les statistiques
démographiques la population générale
les femmes représentent plus de la
moitié
et si une femme est suisse ou bien
sensibilisés sur une question importante
je pense que c'est toute une famille qui
est sensibilisé et c'est toute une
communauté qui est sensibilisée voilà
pourquoi nous avons pris comme cibles
pour travailler sur les les solutions de
réchauffement climatique
la femme en général
et il s'agit de quelle femme comme
cette fille a débuté son histoire avec
son appartenance
sadir
venue d'une localité
peysales il faut encore retourné envers
ces femmes rurales donc nous travaillons
avec les femmes rurales sur les
techniques de création des forêts
communautaires
pourquoi nous le faisons
parce nous avons nous nous sommes dit
cornes apprennent à bien informer les
femmes sur la création des forêts
communautaires ça va contribuer à
réduire les émissions sadis forêts là
vont contribuer dans le train à réduire
le réchauffement ou via les émissions
plutôt les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre qui détruisent notre couche
d'ozone
donc voilà une action concrète que les
femmes en trouver mais connaissant
la vie les conditions sociales les
conditions économiques de ces femmes on
va maintenant les initier à très les
forêts sachant pertinemment que c'est
fort c'est un investissement bien cette
action c'est un investissement à long
terme
comment nous procédons pour qu'elles
puissent bénéficier tout en entretenant
pour injure à ces forêts là nous les
appelons à associer ses plantations à
une culture
agricole et c'est ce que les techniciens
a fait appel à vraux ces efforts aient
serré donc nous le faisons mais c'est ça
l'idée précise pas qui est derrière
notre initiative apporter notre pierre
en amenant les femmes à aller re boisé
là où elle avait contribué à déboiser
mais vous savez pertinemment que
pourquoi être des roses c'est pour
subvenir à leurs besoins il faut
chercher maintenant une autre activité
ou bien une mesure adéquate pour voir
les permettre de ne plus utiliser les
ressources naturelles sources de revenus
dans de là elles ont pensé
disons
affable avec sa femme nous avons pensé à
à une autre activité comme nous sommes 2
d'une population et c'est sûrement
agricole
et l'eau
et ne sont plus aussi riche pour une
bonne production et rentabilité il
fallait passer à d'autres techniques que
nous appelons les bonnes manières de
gestion durable des ressources
naturelles ou des ressources en eau de
la terre
donc vous voyez pleut
c'est une autre technique pour amener
les femmes à faire l'agriculture
et partant de là elles vont abandonner
ce que nous appelons les bacs l'abattage
des arbres pour le charbon pour le bois
de chauffe passé elle va toujours avoir
besoin des moyens pour s'occuper de sa
famille il faut chercher d'autres
techniques pour qu'elles puissent aussi
et gérer d'une façon durable les
prochains jours les forêts qu'elles ont
mises à sa place
voilà une idée par rapport à ce que nous
avons bien nous sommes en train de faire
parce que nous ne sommes pas les
décideurs pour le palais que seulement
l'es10 coup mais nous sommes allés
immédiatement avec les femmes et nous
essayons d'apporter notre pierre pour
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique
et de là il faut aussi passer à autre
chose
cette chose c'est quoi si nous apprenons
les femmes
à reboiser attelé des forêts
communautaires il faut aussi chercher
les moins il faut aussi chercher les
mesures les techniques adéquates pour le
dur kouassi durablement l'utilisation de
bois et du charbon
c'est là bas nous tombons sur la
technique des de l'utilisation des
foyers améliorés
quant à eux n'ont pas les moyens
suffisants pour en acheter
nous les entraînements avec l'appui des
techniciens
a qu à faire leurs propres foyers
améliorés si vous voyez les images de
voir vous vous allez voir et je suis au
fait le village ça fait finalement que
s'il vous plaît non les foyers
traditionnels que nous utilisons avec
trois pierres tu es obligé de mètres de
part et d'autre les toits côté le bois
et les bois pour pouvoir faire plus le
ton alimentation mais avec cette
technique des foyers améliorés que nous
apprenons bien nous essayons d'initier
les fins vous voyez même les feuilles
sèches vous pouvez utiliser pour la
faire cuire vaudra à lima elles ne sont
pas restés là on a aussi pensé à
d'autres femmes qui peuvent
utiliser d'autres foyers améliorés mais
ville conditions limitées nous avons
négocié avec les projets qui
subventionne cette fois hélas
être abordable et accessible à toutes
les femmes
donc voilà ce que nous faisons les
actions c'est pourquoi nous avons
intitulé notre présentation les actions
concrètes des femmes da le réchauffement
bien dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique au togo voilà
ce que nous faisons et pour accompagner
les femmes et les femmes au jeudi
antimoine
d'autres même nous font encore la cour
il nous appelle on a plus que vous avez
créé des forêts communautaires ici
pourquoi pas nous vous comprenez les
portages pc femmes apportent à ce projet
à cette initiative et
cette initiative nous l'avons étendue
sur toute l'étendue du territoire doc
stadi du lot mais à 5 assez et nous
avons aussi et cette technique de les
accompagner allez fournissons les plans
c'est de notre ressort c'est
l'accompagnement que nous apportons ces
femmes là il faut aussi aller négocier
avec le prix des lettres pour ptt rien
passé vous savez pertinemment que la
femme l'a pas droit à la terre du moins
ce de ma localité ou bien dans plusieurs
localités du togo si nous voulons créer
un forum ou une forêt plutôt qu'aux
militaires nous allons vers les épopées
terrier et nous essayons de négocier et
qu on accorde des parcelles pour les
femmes ça aussi ça aider les femmes
passent et les associés comme je le
disais que mes remarques elle associe la
couture à ces plantations la lvf outre
cette culture et agricole est elle
maintenant assurent les besoins
quotidiens auxquels font face dans leur
famille c'est ça aussi qui va lutter
contre est ce que nous appelons la
pauvreté dans nos milieux reculer et ça
contribue aussi à l'autonomisation de la
femme comme nous clame en rose tous les
jours voilà un peu ce que nous faisons
et les actions que nous menons avec les
fins mais il ya aussi un côté pour ne
doit pas oublier le côté informel ce
côté informel c'est à dire si nous
prenons le commerce nous prenons
l'agriculture
les femmes sont plus de haut niveau du
commerce les femmes sont plus de
54% ou bien représente 54% dans ce
secteur et au niveau de l'agriculture
elle représente plus de 6 quand toi pour
ça non vous voyez combien de fois il est
nécessaire qu'on aille vers cette
population pour le sensibiliser sur les
effets néfastes
de documents que nous avons et ce pour
ne pouvoir apporter pas ceux d'autres
pays qui est mexes peut-être qu'ils ont
beaucoup d' usine qui émettent des gaz à
effet de serre y peuvent se dire que
c'est comme ça et c'est leur manière de
fait nous aussi comme nous contribuions
si nous prenons aussi les statistiques
faurecia que nous avons vous savez
pertinemment avec moi vous combinez pour
le togo n'est pas un pays forestier
donc nous
la superficie nationale
nous n'avons que 6,8 pour sa de
couverture forestier mais la
déforestation
jusqu'aujourd'hui nous avons bien nous
arrêterons par a attribué ce que pour ça
vous comprenez combien de fois on
devrait tout le monde devrait apporter
sa pierre pour lutter contre ce fléau
qui est une cause
des doubiens du réchauffement climatique
donc c'est sûr à cette présentation que
j'allais demander à tout un chacun parce
que nous avons des perspectives dans nos
visions et cette festive c'est d'amener
tout le monde d'ici 2030 à
s'habituer à la mobilité vers ce qui
consiste à l'utilisation des machines
électriques des motos et l'éthique que
nos les espérons avec le temps avoir sur
la l'autre territoire national et aussi
privilégier la marche qui contribue à
notre 100e et qui n'a aucun effet sur la
nature sur ce j'appelle tout le monde
que à la sortie d'ici que tout le monde
fasse une action concrète pour
réduire les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre donc je vous
remercie pour votre aimable
[Applaudissements]